so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dobasiolo whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast i am
here with my co-host marty o'neal what's
up folks what up uh sorry if my voice
sounded a little rashy i am tired i just
got off the plane just got back from new
york first time ever
just got here marty just got here i
should have john roll queued up on the
board right now dude i'm telling you man
every i not one person talked like jaw
rule and i was waiting for it i was
waiting they weren't all walking around
murder not even that just like
ah where's my stereotypes of oh
you want to hear something crazy
i didn't see one rant
i stayed in times square okay times
square used to be the main infestation
that's what my homies told me y'all be
careful where you know don't worry like
slides and stuff like uh-huh oh
i get that one yeah i don't remember
seeing a lot of rats in new york they
said there's more rats than people but
for sure if there's a vision infestation
man yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
people too but here we are guys this is
the first uh
like couple hours that i've been back i
just got off the plane uh that time
change
i didn't know
monster yeah also what an advantage the
east coast has over us
like three hours ahead you guys are up
three hours earlier than anyone else
over here not everyone but
whoa what it was 12 and i'm like
some people just got up that was just
been getting up yeah i've been up for
hours
it's weird i remember that i used to
like being ahead of the west coast when
i was in buffalo that's what it feels
like it truly it's uh
different
it's different guys uh i haven't i don't
think i've cussed like a maniac yet
just want to say this guys
besides the land of the plug episode
every episode for the past month has
been age restricted
not even demonetized demonetized that's
that's a given that's a secondary yeah
yeah that's that's nothing dude age
restricted where you can't even see the
video came out it's blocked in some
parts you have to sign into youtube just
to watch our show
um
we're gonna have to start explaining to
the fans guys we need you to create a
gmail account where you're over a team
we need you to be logged in at all times
yeah and like a lot of you like well
it's age-restricted dude kids aren't
supposed to watch it's not that it's
when you let me explain to you when you
log into a uh to youtube or when you go
on youtube on an app right
watch a music video great
what happens that music video is age
restricted you can't watch that video
unless you sign in make an account and
then authorize yes i'm 18 click it click
another pass like 12 clicks you got to
do just to watch one thing people go
i'll watch it later and forget and never
come back and that's how things lose
momentum youtube knows what they're
doing but it's okay we're trying our
best we're trying to clean it up a
little bit there's no smoke in the air i
haven't cussed like a sailor we're
chilling okay so um our porno episode
was all good
yeah it was
our adult film actress episode went
great i thought it was an amazing
episode i had a lot of you jerks being
mean in the chat and then like 10
minutes later go
okay never mind this is cool like just
give it a chance bro we're not going to
bring somebody on it's not going to be
cool i mean hopefully yeah hopefully you
know it's always a risk with every guest
but still like no that was a great
conversation i loved how she was like i
was gonna get my phd but then i just
decided to go get the money and just
[ __ ] live my life uh there's so many
jokes i could have said with you said
that right now i decided to go get a phd
but no like there's a lot of jokes there
a lot of that's what she says
yeah i know i was trying to like not be
that dude the whole time well it's funny
it makes me laugh um
but shout out to adam and uh elena for
being awesome like like i was telling
marty before we got adam 22 on the show
i was thinking
i don't know this man
he seems chill and a lot of times
i see stuff like is he nice is he a nice
dude is he going to be like hollywood on
me
that is the most
helpful guest we've ever had i don't
think i've had a guest go hey man you
got deleted posters back up like
i didn't even ask you
didn't even ask you that's just like a
genuine hey thank you yeah appreciate
you man that type of circles a long way
yeah just just
it's not like oh i need my followers
back it's more of like
you is like oh how can i help out
because that's what i do yeah
thank you thank you man and she was
awesome she said what 20 minutes after
the show to ask about cameras and what
lens should we try and like what are
these like she's trying to do her show
like dialing in so
i love seeing that she was actually like
knowing the different camera models
and like you could tell she'd been
researching it yeah building up her own
studio and stuff dude uh oh also i
watched episode one
of her new show
dude it's uh
it's so bright and poppy color i love it
dude it's like this but like the girl
colors yeah anyway go go check it out um
this is called touchy subject i believe
it's what it's called uh check it out
but anyway yeah last week's episode
super fun
only one that hasn't been age restricted
in a month
for some reason
but we appreciate that so we're trying
to stay clean trying to try to be cool
and trying to hang out um
actually before i forget let me just
talk about this real quick
on my instagram yola underscore youtube
on instagram on my instagram
on my bio you know click the link in the
bio thing there's a button in there
called discord
we have a discord discourse chat where
people hang out they talk they share
links they
excuse me
it's the wii community the dopestyle
weekend if you're a fan we get in there
there's like 10 chat rooms 25 people
each when we first started there was
people in there for 12 hours plus all
day every day just chilling it's like a
hangout spot it was great
so for everyone out there that watched
the show watch discord that was on the
discord discord got
so many die hard fans hate me now
like yo you just banned me from your
discord like what did i even do
bro even i got banned from my own
discord somebody hacked us
and just started
blocking
all the people from the list till he
caught it i
my name is thomas that is my discord
even i got booted i had to make a new
account to get back into my own discord
super weak ass hack is that
right but not even that so many people
don't like me anymore that used to be
super fans first off you getting kicked
out of a discord makes you not a fan
anymore you weren't a fan of being with
bro it's okay it's okay i understand
but it's uh i just want to say it here
because i've had so many people like yo
what the come on bro i was just being
chill like dude even i was kicked out
you think it was purse you think i went
hey this guy's super cool block his ass
i don't have access to the back i'm not
even a moderator like no i don't have
time to moderate a discord for free
a free discord that we just have to
upkeep i have to pay
this is a business i can't spend eight
hours a day doing free discord stuff
maybe eight years ago i could have when
i had the time but i don't have the time
but i love discord going there hangout
chat you know just smoking bowls with
your hands it's cool og hops in there
you see a fool
and uh anyways want to say that for
everyone out there if you were banned
we're trying to find everyone that was
banned and unblocked you know how hard
it is when there's 10 000 people and you
have to go into each account and make
sure what's blocked what's anyway we got
to go through that show on the app too
yes oh man the dopaziola app god there's
so many spam hacker trappers on there we
don't have access to the back end like
wix does wix this is the dopaziola app
wix um is a platform
we noticed they had an app platform like
yo can we try it
60 000 people a week joined it was pop
it was great what happened wick says yo
we can't keep up with this we're not an
app
we don't make weed apps that's not what
we do we're just this is our beta
testing you guys can use it and it went
great but now there's people trying to
post guns and meth and crack and i
should have said that on youtube man
those are key words i'm sorry
ugh
anyway
wix doesn't have the capability to go in
there and scrub it out marty can do it
one by one
all right but marty's busy also the dope
zola app we can't
use it any we can't like make it better
until wix the company makes it better
yeah we just need a little bit more
control in terms of being able to like
have control yeah we're sitting on our
hands yeah but the real purpose of it is
i mean is for those push notifications
that's what we want that was the kind of
the point in the beginning just to be
able to make sure people that want the
notifications can get them and then
having the ability to have your profile
in post and having fun remember like two
days later that's awesome that's great
we only got it for you to get a text
yeah we do at some point after we make
this transition in the new studio and
stuff focus will shift back to that and
cleaning it up and we'll be back on
there every day and showed it's just
hard man like the people
put it this way
if if you had a new app and facebook was
running the app and even facebook like
yo we can't handle it right now we're
not the capabilities well what do you
want us to do we're not coders like i
don't know
yeah like to to really build the app you
got to go hire a developer company no we
didn't do that we got this is like built
into our website so it's like kind of a
beta thing but i mean we do we could
yeah deal we could remember it's all
it's
you have to pay a dollar i don't people
getting so upset like you're a piece of
[ __ ] like but i'm not
i've just filmed for 12 hours for free
[ __ ]
sorry i wasn't in the discord today you
[ __ ] dick
sorry i'm cussing again i'm trying
[Music]
i got hacked we got botted what else do
you want from me you can always make a
new account just get back in the discord
yeah if you didn't say anything not
assume the worst yeah don't assume the
like i'm just like yo evil plan [ __ ]
these dudes the dudes i talk to all the
time [ __ ] you no
people are weird people just assume
weird things
um
yeah so okay let's get that out of the
way ready real quick before i even get
into the new york thing
i know marty marty doesn't know rappers
over the age of 33.
okay i guess you could say that okay
marty there's a rapper named little baby
he's a rapper and he makes music right
he's making money and music he's one of
the bigger rappers that you could say
okay yeah no he put on lil wayne i know
him
what no that's baby
you're tripping okay anyway oh you watch
this clip maybe you could bring it up
mute it but
this fool is on stage
and his security is an offensive line
you go i know a lot of you guys just
went oh i just saw that this morning
dude
excuse me
this fool
it's bad it's i feel bad for the kid oh
i just washed this in the bathroom
yo this kid goes flying 30 feet
bro
that's a death wish right there yeah
i think you're probably getting sued up
through that security guard he need to
push him like that because i mean you
can't push him into other fans
like he was literally going up like this
he just wasn't reaching into his pocket
no i get listen if you wander onto that
stage it's fair game you are i get it
open to anything happening to you but
don't don't throw him into other fans
though bro he threw him so far it's like
he threw him it's like he he uh fresh
prints his ass he he uncle yeah he did
yeah he really did
that's exactly what happened like i
guess you're supposed to like and those
dudes are waiting in the back they're
just grabbing them hoping i don't know
you're supposed to hold on hold on hold
on real quick real quick let me show let
me show you what you're supposed to do
what real quick i've been i've been
saving up my little funny videos over
here oh man hold on hold on you're gonna
uh
hold on hold on let me uh let me just
pull this up real quick all right what
is this
my homie does management for a lot of
artists so i've seen there's a huge
there's a dude a security guard that was
the security guard for like riffraff
little baby and uh i mean the baby a
bunch of other dudes i mean
like seven feet tall with a beard you
probably seen me as a tick tock
i saw that man in person when i was
backstage
i'm not scared of people
i cannot fight that guy
what what can i physically do
like there's only so much you could do
man and like when someone's seven foot
three twenty like all right
here's what he's supposed to do
that's what the security guard was
supposed to do
all right white boys on his feet
oh i seen this one it's sad
he's in a singlet
that little one is a real wrestler the
kid is just a kid
that's not fair
that little kid had a singlet he was
ready he wrestled the kids showed up
there to watch his friend and then he
ended up like boy
that's what the kid that's what you're
supposed to do when you get a free shot
on stage you're supposed to you're
supposed to do some cool wwf [ __ ] i mean
i guess throwing them into the stands is
that but that was a mankind helmet [ __ ]
as soon as i said that i realized that
yeah but i get you
i i don't know man i i just
bro i'm sorry what move would you do you
got you're lurking in the shadows you
got full it's your job goldberg spear
yeah yeah yeah just clean spear
goldberg's spiderman that's all i'm
gonna do i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna raiden
now raiden does the
all the way across the screen or m bison
that's what i'm gonna do to you
uh that's all
or sweet chin music i'm gonna i'm gonna
kick them in the chin
i probably can't kick somebody double
flying
yeah yeah yeah yeah drop kick to the
chest yes yeah what happened why are we
talking about that oh a little bit okay
a little bit i was like yo why am i
talking about this i reference that
movie a lot um
here we go
are we on track can i get one of those
lights
uh we are at what at least 15 minutes
today guys i know we've said it what
we're in the middle of season two today
really is gonna be less than an hour
yeah why because it's sunday
this show comes out tomorrow we hope we
should be doing this live right now we
should be doing this live right now i
just got off a plane we couldn't do it
on the time we left i was so busy i was
filming so many videos my family's in
new york i was at lax till [ __ ] three
in the morning you didn't get in till
when like
i got into lax this morning at 11.
okay but you're this time yeah
it's a lot yeah
it's weird man i left new york two
o'clock la time in the morning mm-hmm
but got here at 11 i don't know i'm
gonna even try to do the math
don't care that [ __ ] just ruins my head
it takes how about the fact it takes
like it takes less time to fly to new
york than it does from new york because
of the wind or some [ __ ]
that'll mean don't want to [ __ ] i
might have made that up but i think it's
true you know what doesn't you know what
i don't want the government just do that
one whatever conspiracy [ __ ] i'ma let it
just
you can have it i don't give a [ __ ] i
hate flying here we go are you ready
can we just touch on that real quick
because
as somebody that hates flying as much as
you
i mean that was just it was cool that
you took rosie on that trip and that you
guys did that because like i would do
everything under my power to avoid a
flight i hate it yeah i hate it so much
you know what i do i look at everybody
that's getting on the plane in the pods
you go you got sisters to live for
no you're on a business call you
wouldn't get on a plane that would crash
i swear to god that's what i do i saw
this family more like
that fool's got like 14 bands of louis
vuitton on he is not dying on a plane
i'm gonna be okay i swear i'm i'm
looking at the pilots like that guy look
cool today
no he's texting i look at the pilots
the pilot's all the way up all right i
got every pilot outside me though
the guy came home this morning hi i'm
scott we're going to be blah blah blah
and then the lady's announcing all the
pilots and she don't say scott's name
and scared the [ __ ] out of me i'm like
yo did you not know the pilot's name i
don't want to be here dude i fell asleep
today first time on the plane i fell
asleep
movie was
dog [ __ ] that's probably why but i fell
asleep and uh i was so happy i woke up
and i'm like oh my god i'm in
missouri thank god because you know you
can see your little your little uh
travel yeah yeah yeah yeah it's nice
when i do that i [ __ ] i just do you
dread the flight up to the flight i did
the whole thing like i'm talking about
the days leading up to the flight are
you is it in your mind about how much
you hate flying and don't want to well i
get there you know what happened today
i'll just say this real quick
the pilot came on and went oh that
doesn't happen often i'm very sorry
about that when i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you we're 30 minutes away from l.a
and we just do this
wing
wing what i went
and i looked at rosie like you're
[ __ ] kidding me it's sunny
and then the pilot two seconds later so
sorry about that everybody uh that
doesn't happen very often rare moment
for me that's not happened to me off i'm
very sorry we caught some turbulence
from the 737 in front of us we got in
his little path and it kind of smacked
us with some turbulence
bro we went like this
i swear to god dude
oh god it hurt i hurt my soul like bro
we're about to go upside down
i don't have a barrel roll
no lie
we went like this
enough for me to shift to rosie shift
away i was pissed oh yeah you just got
to deal with that that's why i [ __ ]
hate you so much yeah there's nothing
you can finally do about it but one
thing why doesn't every chair have a
parachute on it if we're going to crash
can you give me a chance why doesn't the
plane have a
parachute i think about it
[Music]
that was either a really stupid ass
[ __ ] thought or a decent one
okay i mean jets have the little things
to slow them down when they run
why can't we have like 40 giant ones on
a plane it could do something it could
do something
i would feel a lot better about it if i
knew this [ __ ] had appeared so much
better about everything i wouldn't give
a [ __ ] anymore yeah i can't not be
thinking like what if the wing just rips
off bro finally every five seconds i'm
on the window i am this far from 600
miles an hour yeah it's just this yeah
yeah and how about people like rosie
that jump out of planes willingly oh no
she she i don't know if she'll do that
she did the bungee jumping though trust
me she'd [ __ ] do it we talked about
it actually she's like i don't know if i
could
like
i was talking to ariana about it like
you could barely get me on a plane
without having a heart attack could you
imagine you're in the air
the door's open
and you have the wherewithal to get
yourself out of the door and not have a
heart attack and you're able to pull the
[ __ ] cord before you splat into the
ground
i'd be blacking out heart attacking 100
on the way to the airport but i think
if i could have two
parachutes
one on the front
one on the back in case this one doesn't
work
i think i get skydiving and you gotta
log all those practice hours with the
dude on you i only want the dude with me
i don't want to go by myself okay
what am i nobody's gonna hear my last
words my last words are gonna be
hilarious if that should happen you know
what bro i would literally charge up
like you better say some funny ass [ __ ]
before you hit the ground because what's
gonna make it okay nothing you're about
to die might as well say something like
stupid [ __ ] right before
here's another one
leave it in the comments okay
i don't know why i thought of this
but you guys remember day after tomorrow
that's a rant remember day after
tomorrow the whole earth just freezes
adam randomly
it's a stupid movie anyway
wouldn't you pose hella tight
if you're about to freeze to death
yeah i would pose [ __ ] hilarious
you see man i would just be all sad i
would pose [ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
that's literally the only thought i had
in my head right now what pose would you
do it would obviously be the tree push
no i don't think it would be i don't
think it would be i think it
you know more that's a really hard
question first quarter
it'd be it's a really just pose like
that though lighting the georgia
that might be it come on all right no
more thinking that's exactly it like
this
you meant to do it like that but then
you [ __ ] coughed then you froze
i love it sorry let's get on an actual
topic here you ready
um baby joint i lit up just enrolled
just one joint today
there's a multiple because we're trying
to keep this [ __ ] doable yeah like i
said it's sunday i just got off the
plane this [ __ ] comes out tomorrow this
is a this is an interesting week
coming up
what is that
first of all cuz
i'm on uh i got my yearly kind of
vacation in terms of barney's not a dad
today eating [ __ ] done is not one child
in this house
not one their own buff you know they're
all that buffalo
so uh
yeah i've been locking out all these
yola videos cranking out
with a [ __ ] passion
and uh a bunch of other [ __ ] but our boy
omar
ratchet man
hold on
snowboard
there we go
omar hooked me up with a nice stupid
block of studio sessions this week this
week guys
wednesday thursday friday right
yes
and uh
it's been eight years
so you know i've just been this past
week i've been just knocking the rust
off getting back in my groove i'm gonna
put together a little lp
just motivation music for people that
want it and put it out just go have fun
with it for a couple days
that's gonna be sick
it's your first time
yeah i have kids with you you've been
working since you left buffalo you have
main music since you left buffalo and
here it is this is like the nick hogan
week
that's right
yeah
yeah because omar was just like bro i
just did four days we were in the desert
we were just making music he was talking
about being out there with his producer
that yeah he's linking us up with and
just gonna work with first two yeah
so you know uh hold on hold on before we
continue first is like [ __ ] 12 grammy
nominated [ __ ] producer does all post
malone [ __ ] all kali yuji [ __ ] does all
the dope [ __ ]
continue yeah yeah yeah so um you didn't
know that i talked to him i talked to a
rashman about it
months ago and it's a really interesting
story about this about how this is all
coming together we're going to vlog it
i'm going to tell the story more
but that's going to be sick one of my
producers that like i've i met two of my
producers that i worked with when i made
music off myspace
and they're like literally two of my
best friends one of which i've never
even met before in person
for philly yeah but we've known each
other for like almost [ __ ] 20 years
at this point i've known these dudes
longer than april my boy kid and my boy
uh romy chris out of philly so
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell the story a
little bit more on the vlog but yeah me
and him linked back in like oh four my
boy chris out of philly and maybe o5 on
myspace i was going really heavy with
music and so was he and philly as a
producer he'd rap too but uh we were
both like kind of you know he's in like
south philly as a white boy like he was
and he was super [ __ ] reckless too he
was wild but we had a stretch of making
a lot of music together and then you
know i moved out here and he moved down
to florida and got himself together and
really got it together and came back so
when i knew i wanted to do this i
circled right back to him it was like
bro it's time i
when i stopped doing music i said like
if the opportunity ever presents itself
like people want it i'll i could go back
in and do it tomorrow i always said that
to myself every day yeah yeah it's
actually verbatim what you say yeah do
tomorrow so it's like i just can tell in
my heart that it's the right time and i
just want to get this energy off my
chest the whole point of the project is
like
what's transpired since the last time i
recorded wow what it took
what it took to go from that to here now
so you know we'll see what happens but
we're just going to go have some fun
with it and i'm going to i'm going to be
back with vocals
i don't give a [ __ ] if it don't match
we're adding that off
and that uh
he was like ratchet man's like
oh fun fact this used to be nipsy's old
studio oh oh that's what you're going to
do yeah
back of my weed selling this i might
have sold some weed nests yeah no you
been there before yeah i've been there a
few times so that was just another thing
he was like he said there
it was his studio when he died like they
there was a new there was a shrine to
him and [ __ ] plaques all down the
[ __ ]
when i walked in
wow that's a lot of history in this
hallway
you're gonna get that like oh [ __ ] guess
what's been made here
in this room [ __ ] yeah yeah that's what
i need that's what i'm that's what i'm
used to
it's so weird it's so wide i just think
it's crazy like yeah you stop doing that
just to do this
it's [ __ ] now it's on the opposite
side of what you were trying i couldn't
i can't not do it no you can't no i have
to like i feel like an obligation as an
artist just it's too cool of a story to
not come back and just slam dunk it one
time on this and then push off into the
sunset with malcolm here in this
situation you know like i can just feel
it that you know i had just gotten to a
point where it's like i i got sick of
[ __ ] struggle rap like i've been
struggle wrapping my ass off
when we moved out here i was like i
don't want to be that dude anymore
i don't want to be this [ __ ]
struggling dude anymore i just want to
change
and i did here we are so i'm just going
to just going back do it for fun do it
do it for the fans people that want to
listen to it that's what the one other
note i really took from nipsey about his
crenshaw album when he sold when he had
the hundred dollar album that he [ __ ]
sold himself for a hundred dollars uh he
said i'm making this for my fans like
i'm not making it for rap music i'm not
making it for the radio i'm not making
it for anybody other than who wants to
hear it so when i'm going in there i'm
not thinking about what's the smash
single what's going to do well the radio
i'm just going in there to make music
for the people that i don't want to hear
it
that's a it's a very odd balance
because i think about it all the time
i've told well i've talked about on
double joel channel like
making [ __ ] then making [ __ ] because
what's gonna pop yeah is a whole
different thing yeah i don't like it you
morph into that than when you try to
become successful i don't like that you
start off really organic and then as you
like
keep putting your all into it you're
like i'm trying to go towards what's
gonna work
and mix it with my flavor of who i am
but
you know at the end of the day like my
whole my everything depended on rap
before it was like
my whole life kind of was revolving
around like a big
situation popping off with it
so there was just like a lot of
emphasis on it so now it's just like
it's just for fun
it's nice who said it uh jason ella said
it best
there's people out here
struggling this is what they do they're
comedians they're here just trying to
get a spot he's like i don't need it
that's why i [ __ ] loved it yeah
exactly
it's just something i always said i
would love to do and i don't have to do
it to pay my bills there is no stress
i'm having fun exactly here it is this
is the first time you're ever gonna do
that though yeah right yeah yeah yeah
yeah no for sure everything music where
you're not just
struggling every other studio session
before was me going in brimlo [ __ ]
sherlock trying to give these exacts
what they wanted i had years of that
you know just going trying to give other
people what they wanted and just trying
to like
trying to hit that sweet spot of the
right person who i'm dealing with in the
right track and
you know that's cool that's fine i was
had no problem doing that it's just one
of the levels of the [ __ ] yeah but also
i'm not you know i don't care about
being a rapper like that's not my thing
i like it's just one of the things i
like to do creatively that's maybe
that's why podcasting worked out for us
like we just talk yeah the [ __ ] yeah
i don't know what you're talking about
oh there's cameras too yeah and i mean
like if we if we put all our face time
together we have season six mm-hmm um oh
yes because i'm [ __ ] sure and half of
them are like you know i wish we could
say that on the bike that's what we
could cancel but uh another and this
this relates to another thing that i
wasn't gonna um
bring up till it happens but uh
this relates directly to it so
one of our friends linked me up with the
opportunity to speak at a ted talk oh
that's right where's the air
sorry you told me the day before i left
yeah yeah i haven't really processed it
so yeah shout out to wallow a million
dollars worth of gamer
yeah you know he um that's one of those
things where it's like one of those
relationships
back before they even started podcasting
a lot of this yeah we kind of
yeah i was that was that was that but
i'm saying when you're talking to me a
lot of this
come on
yeah
but anyway i kind of helped them out a
little bit back when they first started
and now you know to see where they are
is amazing but he linked me up with with
somebody that could that i got on the
phone with that uh
you know if i if i
choose to do it which i think i'm going
to i'm going to end up being a tedx
speaker
and the way that he was like
framing how to do it was very
interesting because he said
uh if you had if you had to leave earth
tomorrow what's the one message you
would want to leave people with
you know and i was just like because he
had asked me all about my story and you
have to be an expert in something so
what what are you know he already knew
walla already filled him in but he was
like bringing that all about you know
kind of giving him the rundown on my
story and all that and then he said and
i was like because he's you know the way
that they had originally kind of framed
it you know you talk about where you
started your conflict your aha moment
and all that and i was like yeah my life
kind of looking lion's exactly what
you're saying
and then when he said that when he said
like what would you want to leave people
with that's when i was like oh i don't
know what i want to talk about i really
want to think about this and make sure
it's right like that when you do that
that's like your mark like your message
you're like
putting out to people
and i think
for me
and what i'm an expert in in like you
know these digital media related things
i would say i'm an expert in being a
professional artist
that's who i want to that's who i feel
like i'm speaking to
and just how i'm talking this is how it
relates like just how i'm talking about
like yeah i could weave into music and
go record and then weave right back into
all this other you know what i mean like
that's it's the one creative muscle i
feel like that's that's the message i
feel like a lot of people get caught up
in i'm a photographer i'm an audio
engineer i'm a rapper i'm a graphic
designer what are you doing
it's
if somebody asks you what do you do and
you hesitate it's because you do more
than you think yeah i gotta really
explain like um what do i do it's hard
yeah it's hard it's it's and i want
that's my whole thing that i learned
because it's never enough to just be one
thing so you it's i wanna like i think
that's gonna be the core of my message
and accepting that if you're gonna be a
professional artist don't let it just be
i'm a rapper bro i don't [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] yeah that's the worst thing you can
say for sure you know what i do i don't
do this stuff like that's why ratchet
man's becoming successful because
and and it can be oh i'm good at
connecting dots with people he's i'm
there's certain personality types that
just fit in to being a professional
creative i'd say that's a huge part it's
a universal plug-in yeah or ratchet man
is
you'd be shocked on every circle as
[ __ ] linkedin
just because it's like you're a good
person you do good [ __ ] you work hard
hold on now you make music
when omar started making music all his
homies are like shut the [ __ ] up
come to this because all his homies are
[ __ ] famous artists and [ __ ] yeah
like i remember he was telling me he was
like postman i showed him he's like i
should post my [ __ ] music he's like
shut the [ __ ] up we could have been
making music 10 years ago because
laura's been in these studio sessions
for 10 years not making music he's
always the link to dot he used to run
all the diamond uh [ __ ] that's why he's
yeah he's linked to all the atlanta
rappers like omar knows every atlanta
rapper because diamond was heavy in
atlanta like eight years ago
so that's like that's one thing oh like
the ted talk thing
you're gonna have to take some time yeah
and really that message like what's the
last thing yeah like wallows was i
forgave my brother's killer
you know and he got up there and told
that whole story like
going to prison being in prison with his
brother his brother you know like coming
out getting i love all that type of [ __ ]
dude yeah i love it ted talks like
really made a big impact on me when i
all right let's flash back real quick
when i met my cousin that one time the
one who lived in the mansion in la jolla
jaguar ride
jaguar
right of the jaguar oh no this this was
like my dream house the dream mansion in
la jolla oh yeah yeah uh that first
night that i met her
when i was realizing that she looked
like i lived in my dream mansion
she put me on a ted talk she's like you
know i can tell just by like do you know
what ted talks are you should listen to
ted talks and ever since then it was in
my mind that man i loved it like i would
love to get to the point that i'd be
qualified enough that somebody would
want to hear what i have to say in one
of these
you know and it's just
it's cool that it's coming about
hell yeah because that's the thing dude
this podcast is very different
we started like our plan was remember we
started the game plan the skeleton
like yo interject do like come in and
like we'll talk we'll bounce [ __ ] off
each other and the first couple you're
like nah like yeah i'm coming in but i'm
not like
like not like this you know what i mean
it's a whole different story the first
couple episodes i loved them not as much
as i love them now because now it's like
the back and forth like you know what
the [ __ ] i'm saying yeah so
with this podcast it's more of
the only people like yo marty's the
producer but yeah producer co-hosts more
role than i feel than anything because
you could just do this like oh yeah i'm
a producer with this finger
yeah gonna check the cameras like you
know what's about the rest of the 98
[ __ ] like that's what this is
for i can sit here all day and just talk
[ __ ] of course but i like this better
and it's it's more of it's not just me
like ready take me out of the equation
you're about to do ted talk you're doing
all your things you can run the show by
yourself
i think that's what makes us a different
team yeah totally different we're not
comedians when you come in here famous
yeah exactly that's why i say to
everybody like there's that's why we
preached uh entrepreneurs people trying
to make it through the internet and
people trying to do it their own way
like just coming in the little guys the
indie dudes just stoner kids coming and
doing it their way that's why i love
this [ __ ] it's why it's so special
that's why i got to go in and do this
[ __ ]
because it's like you slapping the face
to god not to there you go
i was gonna call the project that slap
in the face to god i was gonna call it
that for that reason because you just
call it youtube restrictions i know she
monetized i was gonna call it that
because i was like it would be not to
right now for me to have achieved this
like everything i wanted
[ __ ]
you gotta go back and do this
but we're not gonna call it that thank
you
the producer chris was like uh i don't
know about that one with his clipboard
uh
yeah i don't know about that
we're trying to we're trying to be cool
in this episode
not get demonetized supposed to talk
about blasphemous things
but it's okay marty's about to go do
this ted talk [ __ ] shout out to wallace
after a million dollars with the game
for hooking that up that's [ __ ]
awesome that's super dope and another
thing of
man i love when people are just genuine
he didn't have to do that for you at all
yeah
i just love everything i love how i [ __ ]
with those fools same message i [ __ ]
with those fools they were very
real that got mainstream somehow mm-hmm
because that doesn't happen often where
real subjects get i mean rogan's
different he was fear factor he's on
news radio he's famous he's a famous
dude
and he's a [ __ ] comedian like he's a
world [ __ ] theater comedian yeah of
course that's a huge platform but for
those dudes to get the deal they got
yeah when we first started he's like
million dollars worth of game because
when they started marty was like talking
to him trying to like help i'm not going
to talk about all of it but
you always say that that's us we're just
going to very similar to our things yeah
when we're in the same field but we're
different people kind of like the west
coast version that's what you said the
west coast version that's what it was
because they're they're similar in that
like gilly's like a famous rapper he's
got that whole thing going on already
wallace motivational uh you know speaker
uh just like they have the things going
on outside of the podcast
yeah exactly i love that [ __ ] yeah yeah
and the fact that you you're behind the
scenes on all everything i do
it's never been there's never been a
situation so tied in i don't think it's
like this
it's literally locked together there's
nothing multiple levels multiple
like connections independently owned
businesses under the umbrella of each
other kind of holding each other up
yeah that's i don't i i
could really you know look back and try
to think about it but
you know that's like jay-z and dame dash
did with their [ __ ] cocaine money is
like what we did with push trees and
youtube and [ __ ]
i don't know
this is illegal
all right government hhc you can check
my accounts
we can check everything cpa
i am good
okay
oh
let's go all right here we go here we go
what time we have now
uh let's see here about 40. ready to
talk about new york yeah we're talking
all right let's get into a little bit of
new york
what's up guys today's episode is
sponsored by our friends over at
seatgeek you guys already know it's the
easiest place it's the best deals you're
ever going to find for concerts sporting
events anything you want to do before
you get into it download seek geek and
once you do use code dope as usual at
checkout and that's 20 off of any ticket
you buy because remember you were gonna
go to that show or concert anyway you
might as well use our code help us out
and get 20 off so that's what i was
saying rosie and i were just in new york
we went to the phantom of the opera went
to the book of mormon every single
ticket we got we got from seek geek and
we got him last minute once you got it
locked in guys at checkout use code dope
as usual all one word and it's 20 off
your ticket you might as well use it it
pays for parking so once again shout out
to our friends over at seatgeek for
giving us the hookup giving you guys the
discount and remember every time you
support sea geek you support the dope as
usual podcast thank you for supporting
the brands that support us back to the
episode
here we go
so i've never been
to new york
all right i have my my favorite show
are all east coast
seinfeld the office everything's east
coast i see brick buildings i tell rosie
all the time i just want to see a full
brick building i've never seen one
before
there's one in la right by the [ __ ]
five that i saw a brick building a brick
built i've never seen a brick building
like a brick
a brick building like in home alone when
he's going to his uncle lost in new york
when he's climbing up the little thing
they make all the tr by the way kevin
mcallister is a dead body
you think two [ __ ] felons are gonna
be like let's chase him watch for the
marbles like no you're gonna get shot in
the back of the head it's over
sorry continue
like that i want to see a brick building
so i'm very excited that the second we
got there i saw what you guys call the
projects and i went oh [ __ ] those are
all brick buildings and they are
identical it's like gta copy paste
there's like 12 when we're in queens or
whatever yeah they're expensive
they're all copy based buildings they
look identical they're all huge as hell
the fool's hanging out in the middle of
like
the grass area of the
uh
you just get shot in california you'll
hang out like that
like in the middle of the spot unless
it's the park
it was very odd to see like how much
camaraderie all these fools are like yo
what like fools are just chilling
it's not like that or at least for me
it's not like that like you don't hang
out out in the open
yeah well it's not it's
i mean it's not such a raging gang land
over there i don't think like that i
don't know but i'm just saying for me
like that's the first thing you know i
was like wow hello people are just
chilling together
that's the first thing i thought cause
you know what's the first thing you hear
new yorkers are mean you better get the
[ __ ] out of the way
i'm gonna say it right now
i didn't meet one mean person no not one
person made me upset not one person was
[ __ ] rude to me
not one [ __ ] human
you ready
real quick
let's get fast forward right now
i'm walking down the street there's this
homeless dude i'm very observant i'm
like all right almost got
got half his clothes hanging off
shorts are [ __ ] uh hulk
tattered no shirt it's night time
i
if you ever come up to me and you ever
see me like this i don't mean to be
but i am ready to punch you in the mouth
because i don't know who's who so
everyone that walks by me i'm ready to
ba it's quick because i just you know
what i'm saying i use my peripheral with
rosie like if i'm not with rosie i'm
just chilling but i'm with rosie it's a
whole different story like yo fools are
weird i gave you the heads up that
they're all going to be just walking up
to you was that did that happen not once
no [ __ ] that one time all right nobody
came up and bugged me and tried to sell
me a [ __ ] thing
so
i'm walking the chelsea district i think
it's called yeah it's the rich section
oh i don't know there's a [ __ ]
homeless dude and i'm like yo that
motherfucker's cracked out let's deal
with this he's walking up to me and you
know i'm like yo
just look straight don't lock eyes you
know not to lock guys in the wheel wee
wee dink locked when i went [ __ ] all
right
and he walks up to me and i'm like i do
the whole like
rosie's next to me i'm just waiting
because like my thing is to get him away
from rosie as fast as i can because if
they spit or get some blood on her like
i just want to get in front of her so my
thing is like ah i was waiting for it
and this guy comes up he starts talking
directly to him like ah
back up a little bit man you're so gross
like you you're right here
nice man i wasn't gonna hit him because
he was homeless i'm just gonna hit him
because he's a [ __ ] crack at getting
close to me like get the [ __ ] away from
me but also i don't want to punch you
let that taser go a couple times
yeah you know what i'm saying they're
like crackhead [ __ ] but he came up to me
goes hey man i'm like hey what's up man
like i'm trying to keep it concise i'm
never trying to be rude i don't give a
[ __ ] of your crack i'm not going to be
rude to you but what's up man but like
trying to keep it short like all right
see you later goodbye cause i was just
waiting for the light you're going to be
oh [ __ ] i was just waiting for the light
dude
i'm walking and he goes hey
you're a good person
that's a good one so here i could tell
you're a really good person her
she's a person
no he goes she's a good person too her
hair color
that's her hair color i'm like oh you're
gone and he goes
but you're a great person like you have
a great night go have fun and he just
cracked out this older like
like 65 year old black dude maybe maybe
like 50. uh-huh
50 to see he was an older man for sure
but he had like tattered ass clothes he
was he lives outside that's a good pitch
for almost dude just give confidence he
didn't ask me for nothing
he's like you know you guys have you'd
be safe like i could tell you guys are
good people man uh-huh and i'm like
thank you man have a great day so you
too man i walked away and i just looked
back if he was looking back at you
something's up i looked back and he just
went
and he just kept his day and when rosie
i've never been
i've never been
that was the most aggressive polite
thing that probably works more he
probably gets more people
but i'm saying he gets more people
turning back around like hey man you
need some money here like
he probably gets more people with that
pitch than his [ __ ] asking for money
he was not asking nobody for [ __ ] but
i'm saying he was still going to take
your money if you're like bro you need
to something no i totally get you i only
have a card anyway but
he was just like on drugs walking around
asking somebody for [ __ ] but he just and
i looked at rose and go that was the
most polite [ __ ] that's ever happened to
me in my life that man was so nice super
cool you guys be safe i'm like yo yeah
this man is the nicest it's so nice when
people do that genuinely though but i'm
in new york i'm like yo first kraken
experience
all right [ __ ] i'll punch him in my palm
i guess
like i was thinking that like ah
also i need a [ __ ] gun yeah i gotta
stop walking around that again uh-huh
yeah okay sorry continue um
yeah i couldn't believe we should we
should vlog that i want to get my
concealed carry too you didn't see what
happened today what
i don't want to say all the keywords
because youtube state of california
conceals just say nerf
state of california you can now hold
your nerf gun concealed any any citizen
in california
of age that's not a felon i never didn't
hear that last week it passed
huh two days before i left i went so i
could
legally
but if you have a marijuana card it
avoids it
they went 90 everybody just got a gun oh
98 just took them back [ __ ]
isn't that crazy you can't like have
possession you could be cannabis yeah i
mean drunk as [ __ ] though yep because i
was thinking what was it wait there's a
medical patient yeah but like wreck
you're fine they're crazy no no no no
you cannot
having weed in the car with your
concealed it voids it you know oh
okay i got you isn't that stupid i
should look more into the laws
because
i mean i looked at it i just saw the
article i'm like wow
i just said yes you know i need a gun
right right here when i drive
i need one right here because fools are
wild out here and um
i mean at home is a different story but
i'm not gonna just drive around with
shotguns in my car
on the back seat of the benz oh a gun
rack
hi wayne
i don't even own a gun
uh gun rack i watched uh wayne's world
on the trip on the flight here today so
it's in my head still
um
yo yeah i want 10 guns
yeah i want 10 nerf nerf air sauce
um yeah yeah dude oh sorry sorry new
york
that man was so polite
we get there we go to a restaurant
me and rosie always get lucky we always
find random stuff and people like how
did you even get in you didn't have to
make a reservation or sometimes when i
buy rosie something
she'll post it like oh thomas bought me
this is so i'm so cool like oh awesome
and her friends how did you get that
there was only [ __ ] one drop and it
came out [ __ ] last week how did you
12 times if i bought like 15 things at a
store 12 of the times ever
how did you get it the shoes i just got
the other day i'm like yo how did you
get though there's only four in america
how do i know
i just went into a store and bought them
happening every time i go like we
actually got one like the car we have
one amg actually yeah we've just been
getting lucky yeah random things
so we go to this restaurant there's five
people in the restaurant apparently
there's like a month wait on this
restaurant
had no idea
there was no it was almost closing when
we got in there
yo some of the best vegans we've ever
had in my damn life
let me just say this real quick
whatever high-ass [ __ ] thought
of the sandwich
thank you thank you
are you guys ready huh i looked at the
sandwich and went it's too wild for me
to say no
green apple slices peanut butter yeah
aioli
chipotle aioli okay
vegan prosciutto or some [ __ ] i don't
know something like soy [ __ ] i don't
really like it
smoked
mozzarella and like four or five other
things avocado
thank you i went
i gotta get this [ __ ]
let me get it let me get it uh-huh it
was so damn good i took the fake meat
out i don't [ __ ] feed me yeah i took
it out like this is one of the best
sandwiches i've ever had i can't believe
it anyway i don't remember what the
place is called but it was really nice
really crazy last time i was on set it
sounds so simple the thing that was
everybody was taken out of the craft
services
apple slice peanut butter apple slice
sandwich
how did i never think of that as a kid
like that that's the most wholesome
thing you give a [ __ ] person wow it
sounds bombs [ __ ] actually i'm so hungry
sorry i'm just off a plane
[Laughter]
bad
when i was in uh new york
i got on the subway to a dead homeless
person oh
just you open up the door i'll never
[ __ ] forget the smell
one of those like what happened
he was just dead
i mean did someone kill him no i don't
he was just in the corner he was just
like i think he just died oh man that's
sad
and people were just [ __ ] walking
past it it was clearly dead
and uh yeah i mean like the subway
account it was carrying on i mean i'm
sure like somebody [ __ ] told somebody
at some point but that's that new york
city [ __ ]
okay
hold on so i'm in new york that's
another thing i want to talk about
i've never felt insane so insignificant
and i loved it so much i just loved it
fade into the crowd nobody's looking at
me not like yo tom it's not like that
i'm talking about like say i never did
dope pajala [ __ ] you're around humans
and people bug you not in new york
people got [ __ ] to do like not on top of
like you can take a picture [ __ ] that
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about as a human being
you don't [ __ ] matter because that
fool's got seven things to do get the
[ __ ] out of the way
it was so odd to me everyone has
something to do everyone's got somewhere
to go every [ __ ] bar is full every
restaurant has people
but there's 6 000 restaurants on that
[ __ ] block how are they all full how
are there so many humans in here and
then i look up and go oh
it goes up it goes up
but did you notice that there wasn't so
much just rampant homelessness like i
saw like four homeless yeah like five
and i was on the strip uh-huh
where's all the homeless people
it's too cold for that [ __ ] i guess or
where did they go like they're just
where's the pigeon lady when i got out
when i got out to the west coast i was
like what is happening to the sun you
can sleep and eat fruit off a tree like
you get this advice out here and go hey
kid give me your help not like that
you'll get more just like regular people
just walking up to you trying to [ __ ]
just hustly out of some [ __ ] like yo all
right look at
i like new york better than la a lot
better is way cooler
there's more stuff the one thing i'll
say i really excited i appreciate it is
[ __ ] will wear a 40 year old
shirt
because it's a shirt
like i don't know if that makes it like
i saw so many dudes walking around there
was like 7 000 different fashion styles
i saw
okay like there's this dude he's wearing
everything from the 40s because his
grandpa left it to him and look at this
guy he's wearing [ __ ] doc martens and
a see-through [ __ ] see-through gold
pants
like i [ __ ] love it here everyone's
like oh i don't give a [ __ ] that you can
see the outline of my dick
i'm wearing what i'm wearing yeah it was
so cool bro like uh like isolated
there's a like we went to the like the
guess you would call it the castro
district from la i mean from frisco it's
where like the gay pride like where it's
very very present
we walk through that area i'm like whoa
this is tight as [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ]
that's what i noticed like nobody cares
they're just living their life and you
can go over there get the [ __ ] out of
here then
but here it's more like everyone makes a
big [ __ ] deal about every single
thing and over there i felt like i saw a
dude get out of his car when i was
waiting for a thing i'll punch you in
your [ __ ] mouth and he grabs a guy by
the shirt get the [ __ ] out of my way do
it again what the [ __ ] happens he gets
in his car and the guy just drives off
normal he's back on his phone like he
didn't get punked yeah
you would have your whole family has to
die here basically like dude something
has to happen there's no way someone's
gonna let that slide if you grab me with
my [ __ ] shirt in traffic i'm gonna
kill your ass
the guy just went all right
roll his window back up put back on his
phone
people were screaming at each other all
right man
all right get the [ __ ] out then go
and they just
continued their life yeah i've never
seen
so much slight aggression and go all
right my bad go
i didn't meet one rude [ __ ] not
one rude person
wow
no cashier was a [ __ ] to me
dude people are rooting me every [ __ ]
five minutes in l.a i don't know what it
is and i'm so smiley and nice i don't
get it but when i went there i was
expecting the worst because i've seen
the
movies
nah shout out to new york also shout out
i didn't walk around a lot but when i
did
yo we got a lot of [ __ ] fans in new
york nice thank you guys like a lot of
fans bro it was [ __ ] cool dude
and everyone
what the [ __ ] you doing every single
person
in new york
so many people do like and i met uh i
can't remember this i met this fool
i'm so tired i met him last night
i felt like days ago uh-huh
at washington square park or something
oh we were smoking a joint
and the dude runs across the street like
stops he goes what what is that yo what
the [ __ ] he's like i just got here shout
out to you he's from frisco blond kid uh
from frisco
and he's like yeah i just got here i'm
just chilling watching square farms i'm
smoking and joining like i watched you i
was just watching your video
but everyone like every single person
like i just what the [ __ ] i was just
watching this video every every one of
them like yo i [ __ ] love this place
man that's awesome everybody was so nice
and they had this little dispensaries
and [ __ ] popping up which was there was
bead vans everywhere vans on every
corner we cush this that like 60 [ __ ]
fake pigs regular real weed too right
also
i came across a dispensary and their
whole logo was that
the hobbies for life [ __ ] yeah no it was
cool it's fine it's cool i just went
oh that's wow that's unique i mean i'm
just like me the human that made this
[ __ ] just happens to me walking down the
street it was on their uh chalkboard
like of their specials outside the door
like it had that hella big as their yeah
can a club or something
and shout out to i think it's like
bodega
ah it's in my phone bodega
um
i think it's bodega i can't remember the
thing it's about it's a delivery service
i was walking down the street fool's
like y'all watch your [ __ ] they gave me
[ __ ] like an eighth i haven't even
smoked yet of carbon fiber i think it's
called shout out to you and the other
dudes from socal the blonde dude that
was with him i have a great memory i
just i just screenshotted it where i saw
him
but uh black white shirt with one little
logo on i just i'm just picturing what i
saw
and then i think was his name skinny i
think a shout out to skinny this kid
this dude from [ __ ] uh from new york
i literally turned around and another
dude was like yo what the [ __ ]
why are you here anyway i saw him and
then i'm walking around i see him again
he's sitting in a restaurant and he's
rolling the [ __ ] joint on the just
out in the open
at the restaurant with his jar i'm like
you can just roll he goes dude yeah
i didn't okay i just smoked one piece of
wood i didn't roll one joint i brought a
zip i didn't even touch it because i
smoked hash the whole time hash pens i
brought an e-rig i was smoking hell ass
rosin because i didn't think you could
walk around smoke weed in there this
fool was wrong shout out to skinny for
changing my perspective
on new york weed culture because now i'm
gonna go smoke it the [ __ ] up when i go
next i'm gonna
smoke whatever i want i'm gonna have
these on deck cause i was just hitting
hash pens like uh-huh
yeah i didn't know because you tell me
the horse yeah i've never not just been
scared like he's like no he had a jar of
fire looking weed on the table on the
table outside of the restaurant it's
crazy as they're eating that's amazing
that makes me so happy inside
everyone smoking weed yeah
that's how it should be i smell i
smelled 90 more wheat
than cigarettes hmm no no i probably
smelled cigarettes like four [ __ ]
times
and there was so much weed smoke going
on dude that's washington square park
everyone was smoking weed it was cool
nyc or nyu is right there dude new york
is cool man i really like
i finally every building's haunted but
it it's cool every building is like from
night
1840
yeah historic control also you guys
share hallways to get inside of your
house this is crazy like those brown
stones yeah
you walk in and there's individual doors
and it goes into your it's like a
townhouse basically yeah
yeah no like they go into a hallway your
mailbox yeah a common area but it's part
of your house
exactly yeah that's
crazy to me yes we have a lobby i live
in the uh apartment now i get it
it's different there
well my homies uh mallory and doug
they're from long island and they came
out we chill with them they're they're
somewhere they're [ __ ] awesome
they came out they're showing us to
locals right
some people share bathrooms
some apartments like yo we have like
seven
rooms on this floor there's the bathroom
and i thought but what happens if
someone's a nasty [ __ ] of course they
both would just complain that's what
they both said so i'm like
that's it
i gotta worry about this [ __ ] guy
next to me [ __ ] on the toilet
i'm gonna move i'm gonna leave go to
another state
new york people are there's no privacy
everyone's shoulder to shoulder but no
one's bugging each other
it was so odd i've never been in such a
situation where people like you know i
don't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
either yeah like meow meow i don't give
a [ __ ] yeah that's exactly thank you
yeah
that's how i feel if i bust a camera no
one's going to stop me and go
here i wait for people to pass i don't
want to like
yeah
people just [ __ ] stu
yes i'm on camera but it's just me and
marty here i don't know like 90
strangers staring at me without venice
like yeah
it is weird but over there i busted my
camera and no one looked twice at me
just my business mine and their business
loved it and i'm not saying you see me
filming don't say hi that's not what i'm
saying i'm talking about people that
don't give a [ __ ] yeah just staring at
me that's why i like filming on
hollywood boulevard it's just weird yeah
yeah it is i just like i don't like
attention i don't like attention
i'm like that too i want to be a [ __ ]
shadow
leave me alone
yeah i was um i was watching back season
one and i actually said something in
season one real [ __ ] stupid about new
york city what
and i wanted to clean up
uh i was telling the story about when i
stayed with my boy's family when i met
50 cent down there
and they were muslim and a lot of my
friends that i grew up with from
makawana are muslim iran
i mistakenly said
i said something like about muslim
people not liking white people
i didn't mean it like that
i was like because i was just i said i
was like i i remember i was i was giving
the vibes that they're very like
this way and all that
and i was like
you're like what they i what i meant by
that was growing up like if i was in the
car with my my boys that are arabian and
muslim like we're hanging out i'd have
to drop them off
streets over so they could walk home
because they couldn't be seen hanging
out with me
like you couldn't it was against the
rules
for them to hang out
uh a muslim girl could not like talk to
her be with a white kid this was just
known in la cuando it was a thing
it wasn't i wasn't like offended by it
but i knew if we're hanging out some not
all of the kids
but some of their kids that were more
strict like they had their own society
going
but some of my all-time best friends
are muslim yemenis kids got a lack one
alert
it just made me bad made me feel bad
when i listened back to the episode and
heard myself say that because it's not
what i meant well i was trying to like
be like despite that these people were
letting me a stranger stay in their
house on their couch i remember driving
me around doing everything they could
for me marty's [ __ ] racist
so that's what i'm trying to get to
yeah so that bothered me i want to clean
that up
marty you see this this means not
[ __ ] welcome
you know i've done that to so many
people like there's nothing there like i
know i know there's no tattoo there sir
and you're white
this is a joke
so funny so i like the clarification
yeah 11 months later yeah it was
probably even longer but i just i've
been listening to season one back a
little bit and i you know that bothered
me that bothered me
well actually there's something i wanted
to bring up um nothing bothers me
everything has ever said everything i've
ever said i stand by unless i went wait
yeah no you know what no that was dumb
i was standing by everything except for
that one yeah
me too
that one correctly um also on the way
there to calm me from the fear of dying
i watch forrest gump god i love forrest
gump i i there's a reason why it's my
favorite movie it's the best movie ever
[ __ ] made it is so
dope
that's all i have to say and then watch
the happy gilmore that's literally all i
have to say andrew major and i want to
remind you today wayne's world today
yeah yeah it was bomb gotchaman she's
good as [ __ ] too
god i just love i [ __ ] love movies
anyway back to new york here we go um i
got pizza finally last night
dog [ __ ] vegan pizza vegan pizza of
course i know
but the other pieces look bomb as well
yeah yo why is the pizza so cheap how is
it so cheap
people you could just only you can close
down everything but pizza and people go
no it's fine
there's pizza every two steps dude 99
cent 99 cent pizza one dollar slice and
drink uh joe's pizza like there was so
much pizza and i couldn't eat any of
that she didn't look bomb as [ __ ]
um but last night i went to a place
and i got vegan pizza and it was not
good
and that was it and that's all i got to
say about that
um but here we go marty's changing out
this battery real quick and uh while he
does that i'm gonna light this up real
quick smoke dis
drink this
and then we'll get back to this next
part because i finally got to go to
broadway shows i went to multiple shows
i'd even tell you yet marty
we're gonna get into that right now
um
here we go so
rosie and i just walked around certain
spots
ubered a lot
went to a bunch of different vegan spots
vegan food places
um we were gonna go to strip clubs and i
thought you know what cove is rampant
right now let's just not go to strip
clothes in this crowd at a little tiny
place
so we didn't
one thing we didn't do we didn't go we
didn't do that we didn't go to any
anything really went shopping a lot of
spots but
like i said we went to the gucci store
or whatever
who gives a [ __ ] it's a store cool
outside
it's like
200 year old castle churches
people just walk by this [ __ ] don't
stare at it
that's appalling to me like yo you don't
just stare at this [ __ ] building it's
a black
painted church from like 17 something
you're not looking at it
shocking blows my [ __ ] mind
every building had like a gargoyle
i'm just staring at everything like this
is amazing dude that is a big difference
yeah [ __ ] out here is all mediterranean
and all like sleek and [ __ ] everything
had like cool stuff
i don't know anyway
rosie and i uh finally go to a show and
that's the book of mormon do you know
what the book of mormon is
trey stone and matt parker
you're you're getting good it's matt
stone and trey parker okay you're
getting real good though
you're getting good
unless i'm wrong but i know i'm not um
so here we go
yo
i went it's book of mormon okay it's
written those two people he just named
are the writers of creators of south
park they have the number one broadway
of all time it's number one
same show
same show over and over and over two
times a [ __ ] day forever
people in and out and that's what blew
my mind i'm looking around the theater
going
all these people have lives
have car insurance
you know they pay a phone bill
they eat places they know multiple
people
the earth is big man
being there really broke it down for me
like
i've been walking for five minutes and
i've heard english once
this is insane like this is a different
place and i like it
i just i don't know there's something
about it made me feel like god i don't
like being in merced
like there's so much more outside of
merced
no like
before i ever moved yeah i would have
never thought to travel to places
[Music]
for what but now that i see that i'm
like yo that motherfucker's wearing a
suit
whoa these fools are smoking cigars at
lunch yeah
it doesn't make you feel like
insignificant but just like kind of like
a speck amongst other specks that thank
you thank you it made me feel like wow
there's so much more than just what i'm
doing because i get stuck in my own
world dude
for the past
32 years
i have been stuck just doing what i'm
doing looking around and when i really
stop and just look like that guy has a
kid that kid has to go to school that
kid's gonna go back to school talk about
his [ __ ] new york trip and in 10
years he's like yo i'm going to new york
and in 10 years i'm going to be thinking
about that and we'll probably be
standing next to each other somewhere in
l.a something weird
earth is weird earth is weird
then you start mad
whoa then you start scaling i'll i'll
start thinking like that and then i'll
start thinking back like
everybody that's ever lived oh that's
different start that's great you you
start like getting out of your element
you start realizing god there's so many
other [ __ ] going on other people all
their different lives and then you're
like
you know when it kept coming back to me
how can i sell every one of you
something
how can i do something that every one of
you wants not needs just wants
i don't want to sell you
medicine that's not fair
like what do you guys all want
i'm looking around like every taurus
does what
smoke weed no i look down like wow walk
shoes
how could we make a bed and then i saw
everybody wearing new balance and went
you know they kind of got to unlock and
i just kept walking after that i swear
to god i saw two people back then
yeah new balance kind of does that they
got a lockdown i'm gonna keep going
speaking of shoes i watched jumanji pair
of shoes this morning
uh anyway um
so book of mormon
[ __ ]
i've never seen a show i've never seen a
play i've never seen actors i've never
seen
things move i was so shocked like
i don't know what movie i can compare it
to when the person like the kid gets
that moment of like whoa
that's what happened to me
i'm sitting there watching these actors
and like wow
every one of you is trained every one of
you goes home every one of you goes to
thanksgiving what are you doing i'm
actually on broadway now about every
[ __ ] one of you has made a post on
social media like it just really broke
down like
[ __ ] me up i'm thinking about this the
whole time
so
book of mormon hysterical it is just a
movie
broadway and when the
curtains go and it goes next scene
that's just a transition of a movie
gotcha like an act it's an act it's just
the scene
like i get it and i'm like yeah you
didn't know this yeah i knew this but
seeing in person is different [ __ ] you
people don't really know this [ __ ] it
blew my mind the lights would go black
and you could see a few specks of actors
moving
lights would go on in two seconds as
another set
they already came in in the darkness
switched it ran off
i was [ __ ] shocked anyway book of
mormon funny as [ __ ] i wish it was a
movie because i would watch the movie it
was very funny it was awesome the lead
looks just like charlie
my homie charlie i feel like oh okay oh
wow bro and you know charlie's an actor
it looked like what that's charlie what
the [ __ ] looks just like his ass anyway
cool show seeing the set scene come
everything come in makes me think i just
need a warehouse some time in a budget
and i'm gonna do so many things
seeing the things they did like wow it's
just a background up lighting oh [ __ ]
there's two dudes pulling i love those
moments oh it's just that yeah oh it's
just that okay
that's fake that guy just picked the
whole thing up
the staircase was fake like oh my god it
just blew my mind seeing these things
and knowing oh it could be done i could
i could make a movie i can [ __ ] do it
anyway
super cool we leave
and we're like yo let's get on you know
those you guys ever seen on tv or on
movies where the guy's on a bike but
he's pulling you and another person in a
little carriage
rickshaw thank you you've seen those
right yeah of course
i thought this man was really nice he
looked so genuine he looked like data
from the goonies
so i'm like oh pictures of barrel i [ __ ]
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] all right cool
cool like a little asian guy and we like
yo how long uh how much is it man we
want to go to this restaurant it's like
15 minutes away and he goes it's by time
don't worry get on gotcha got me
i was just like oh i'm tired let's just
stop on
got me
what did i not do kids
ask how much is for my ornament i didn't
ask
i just said oh fine
and i'm not gonna like
too much i should have yeah i didn't
know i didn't it's a weird business
model because they're bracing for a
confrontation hoping that you pay them
that much like that's i think what
happened
he's taking us around
super nice guy never get in one of those
again he's taking us on the street yeah
there's cars on our bumper if they don't
hit the brake they're gonna hit me and
rosie in the back
two steps behind me the whole time i'm
doing this
like holding rosie's back like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] if something comes with my throw
our ass like i just i was i wouldn't
didn't have fun
at the few times there was nobody behind
us i'm like all right whoa
it was cool right
so we get to the restaurant doesn't
exist
it's just an apartment building and he's
like you're gonna eat here
no man
drop us off this [ __ ] street it's
fine
and then i get off and i'm like wow this
isn't the corner where the hookers
talked to kevin mcallister you got you
you're scared kid you're looking for
your mom it looked just like that car
wow
and then he was like hell here's the
price and went oh you [ __ ] and
he goes we did 18 minutes 144 dollars
what yeah
i saw the price on his phone went
eight dollars a minute
[ __ ] goddamn brain surgery [ __ ] you
because while we were going i looked at
the uber and go why are we taking like
so many extra streets oh we're just
sightseeing it's cool
that's what i thought what does he do if
you tell him to [ __ ] himself though and
give him a 10 like it's not even that
it's like i was about to tip the [ __ ]
out of you i thought it was going to be
like 60 bucks just gonna be like yo
here's 100 bro thanks for listening
you're right back you're saying yeah
[ __ ] you dick
you attacked anyway i'm like all right
man here
change
thank you i'm gonna put my chat i never
get my [ __ ] i always like tip the
prices yeah i'm like no i don't want my
[ __ ] change back thank you sir and
then uh the place didn't exist
so um rosie and i are in some skit
that's kind of sketchy but i always look
at the round and go there's old ladies
around i'm good there's old ladies
around we're okay because i don't know
these neighborhoods i know where to go
in california i know where i can and
can't go i can't tell gang bangers in
new york puerto rican dudes i don't know
that [ __ ] yeah you didn't see any
mexicans did you
yeah like five of them they're all my
uber drivers they have to have their
little taxi thing jose fernandez
something else hernandez and another
fernando they might be puerto rican but
they look they look like a mexican they
were little mexicans
and um
[Music]
and yeah dude so i'm looking around
because i don't know this place guys
remember i don't know this area i'm very
like
i need a gun i don't know who the [ __ ]
is who
i don't know who's a nice i can't tell
new york's a different [ __ ] place
nobody dresses like you would think
gang bangers dress
not even gang bears fools of
i won't say there was one time i didn't
even tell rose there was one time like
all this fool's trying to get me wow i
saw like these two [ __ ] kids like
probably 20 something
but they passed me but i had just just
bought some [ __ ] for duo at dior with
rosie i'm like
i don't really want to walk around this
dior box
it's not small
it's definitely your rent
if you can sell it on the black market
you know just sell to somebody yo [ __ ]
yeah i came up all i did was rob this
dude and this girlfriend so i'm walking
and this fool's past me i'm like all
right and i'm just using all the mirrors
like that's one of these like i'm doing
the sightseeing but i'm just looking at
the windows to see if these fools are
behind me still and i waited the lie i
looked back and i see both of them like
looking around the corner at me like
[ __ ]
for real
no knife okay
i'm gonna go ah
if they got a knife i gotta give it up
that's all i can think of they got a
knife because rosie's here [ __ ] if you
don't get a knife be prepared to fight
me that's all i'm gonna never say
but if you've got a knife and i'm with
rosie it's a i can't so like you know
keep it
i'm not gonna go at the hospital sorry
rosie i really wanted to keep the
[ __ ] stuff we bought like
no look that
but i saw him and then i saw him talking
to some other fool and i crossed the
street and i looked back and then one of
the fools around the corner again like
no it's kind of it's coming wow i'm
beyond the pockets like guys i got
[ __ ] robbed
here i was thinking like how is this
gonna go down
damn this sucks and i thought like joe
spiderman ain't real out here bro i'm
about to get robbed
like this is some no there is no batman
this is gotham
and then we went into this speak easy
spot
and we were there for like an hour and a
half we just dipped in i was with my
other homies i'd even tell them because
i know my homie doug would have been
like what's going on mm-hmm could my
homie dug him i already know someone's
like yeah i'm just gonna keep it cool
but i'm just keeping an eye on these
fools and i was like yo they're blogging
on me no
way because as they cross it's like
everybody's eyes if you're just locking
on my bag like [ __ ]
i wish you had a plain bag do you are
you [ __ ]
you should have a new york bag you're
walking around here's a brown bag yeah
something dude
something right
so we dip into this place i'm not gonna
say where
we dip in the place they know it's a
speakeasy it's a restaurant
i'm not gonna i don't wanna give it away
but you go to this certain box thing in
the restaurant it's right by the tables
you get on the phone and you press one
number and you go how many people like
four
then you wait and the wall opens up into
the secret [ __ ] bar
and we went to this bar like in the
basement of a [ __ ] dungeon building
not my scene bro
no no that's where they were taking us
but it just i didn't know when i was
looking back i'm like oh it's right here
my good get inside because these fools
ain't following us in the restaurant i
already know this but i saw him like
[ __ ] dude for real
yo
don't rob me that's all i can think like
don't rob me just watch the show [ __ ]
that's all i can think of yo you would
like me if you just didn't think i'm
about to rob this
it was easy it was easy come on is this
me and rosie walking with nothing in a
bag
i mean doug mallory too but still come
on what i'm gonna do
if you got one knife it's over i can't
risk it
you're cutting somebody from my back um
so i gotta get that pepper spray in that
taser well not even that dude i i didn't
expect to walk around too much in
certain areas especially after buying
[ __ ] so
my own fault
come on i know better i know better
that's why i was just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i hate it here i don't know where to go
but i love it at the same time anyway we
go into this bar
and it's like in the dungeon it's a
taxidermy owl right when i walk in like
whoa
i'm in the 1700s down here it smells
like pirates
something's weird down here yeah but i
ate some tater tots and i drank a drink
and we left went out nobody was there it
rained so violently hard when i was
there
that me rosie had to wait and just like
40 minutes to die we couldn't go
anywhere we were just stuck under an
awning i couldn't believe it dude
i tried to buy an odb toy as big as this
table
but i didn't want to walk around
new york in this [ __ ] area like
with a gigantic through the important
[ __ ] not even that i had to walk around
still i just kept thinking like i got a
gun oh god [ __ ] i can't be walking
around with all my [ __ ] i mean l.a would
be walking around oh my [ __ ] like you
don't walk around with expensive things
but it's a odb toy and it's like this
big
and he's busting through a [ __ ] wall
with a microphone
and it's like you might the toys have
been getting but like a stage one oh
sure i was like wow i'll get that for my
mom and i went i'm not carrying this
[ __ ] and then it started pouring it was
dude people don't give a [ __ ] it's crazy
there's fools on mopeds on the sidewalk
when it was raining to get under the
awnings just driving under
new york's a different place people
don't give a [ __ ] cops aren't stopping
you unless you're doing some [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] imagine being a cop
everybody's standing there
sea of people
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to know what
the [ __ ] is going on
how could you
it was weird
it was awesome though so yeah that's the
only thing i didn't tell rosie yet i'm
like yo i can't even tell you but i can
see all those three fools faces in my
head right now
and i saw him plot he was picking up his
pants like oh no this is i just kept
thinking like let me cross the street
let me get across this street and i just
kept looking back like mugging and
coming [ __ ] and then we dipped in like
thank god bro [ __ ] this
you see that video of the dude in la who
they're about to rob him and he like
throws the [ __ ] off put it over the
fence yep smart
that's my homies uh
my uh well
that's my friend's friend and he was
telling me about it he was telling me
about it recently too
um
yeah so smart did they just let them go
of course
i would think they would not be happy
about that
i mean their their goal is not to kill
you their goal is to rob as many months
if you shoot and kill somebody for their
rolex
you be prepared for the whole [ __ ]
city to be on your ass like you're
robbing rich [ __ ] and killing
them fool's getting robbed all day but
they're not getting arrested really
don't push it if you shoot one of these
fools then it's like yo we need
something to be done and watch what
happens to this crime rate you know i
mean now that's concealed carry is going
on and all that it's great
anyway yeah it's wild it's wild that's
why i was being prepared for like [ __ ]
dude i don't
let's just bottom line it
i don't know the area so i don't know
where i can and can i walk
that was my thing that's why i was on
edge the whole [ __ ] time my anxiety
the whole [ __ ] time like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't know where i'm at
i don't know where i am should have wore
different shoes why did i wear these
shoes it's all like i'm thinking like
[ __ ] can i have hello homies from new
york they're like you never got like
what did you call it you never got your
sneakers in the hallway like what are
you talking about like you never got
robbed in the hallway for your shoes
like no
like yeah just don't go down the
staircase sometimes there's three fools
in there i'm like give me your [ __ ]
are you serious like yeah bro don't wear
the fresh ones never wear them wear them
when you're going to certain my homies
from new york but they were like 10
years older than me but they all they
tell them like y'all me and then
parliament always be prepared well i'm
like [ __ ] man you got me thinking like
it's [ __ ] scary over there it's chill
yeah i wasn't only honest because i
didn't know who and what i cannot do
like i'm like manhattan and [ __ ] you
weren't in the [ __ ] bronx no no i
when i left the tourist areas i was in
this i was in this i went down to the
other sides
um
and i was looking around like oh this is
where the crackheads are and i was
walking around there looking at the
streetwear [ __ ]
but i'm looking around like
good thing it's bright damn
i don't know where it's going
it's grimy out here [ __ ]
smoking blunts i can see that good i can
see [ __ ]
you got a gun
i can see it on you you guys all have
guns but it's cool it's like la but here
i can recognize it that's all i'm just
ignorant to it but i love it that's all
i got to say
love new york it was so fun it's better
than to me
way better experience in la
it's [ __ ] awesome another thing
[ __ ] everybody bitching about real
estate being high here
yo
i'm sorry you live in l if you live in
new york you are tough
you're you're you're grinding hard as
[ __ ] because that is the most expensive
city i've ever experienced
my homie's telling me like how much is
it to buy this like you know this
apartment like to live there bye he's
like
six mil what the [ __ ]
and then we're looking it up yo rent for
a little apartment like mine would be
like nine bands
because it's like it's a nice one yeah
over there oh my god
oh [ __ ]
yo i never go i'll never complain again
oh there's no yard here this is a small
yard oh god that's not no it's not even
a [ __ ] possible over there no one's
got a [ __ ] grass
i'll never complain again i'm never
complaining about there's too many
people next to me why is there so many
fools in here i'll never complain again
new york's just like this yo
you're in line get the [ __ ] away from me
man
all right go go like i saw so many
people like slight arguments but they
weren't arguments it was just aggressive
talking all right bye all right move all
right late it was wild and everybody
honks
everyone's honking at all times but not
like
it's just it's like a thing yeah it's
like a it's it was every uber driver i
drove with yeah this would be a maniac
here
every there's no
lines in the road don't matter there
sorry i know everybody in new york is
like damn this was talking about like
it's crazy i've never experienced this
yeah it's like driving in mexico yeah
they don't give a [ __ ] every car has
scratches on the bumper every [ __ ]
one yeah because everybody's just oh
oh first thing i saw the dude backing in
hit the car behind him pulled up hit the
car in front of him parked
when i was driving around in that time
that i was just talking about the dude's
brother was a cop
so he was like there was times when he
was driving us around and he was really
like
driving like a [ __ ] cop would in his
[ __ ] weird yeah like uh no gone gone
god no lines oh you want to pop up in
the in the [ __ ] almost on the
sidewalk fine
every uber driver don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they're yelling that
[ __ ] don't make you feel like a
[ __ ] like yes when i first popped out
of the holland tunnel into new york and
you're just driving like a regular human
if anybody's sitting around you oh
they're automatically going to be like
you got to go you got to go what the
[ __ ] are you doing like
this takes a minute to get used to this
chaos driving there in tents also i
would never thought i'd say this if i
lived in new york i would not buy a car
i would just walk of course i loved it
dude just being able to walk everywhere
in a couple minutes
every building's a possible studio
with huge walls and like good sound like
all right
i like new york a lot i can see
why people live there
very cool
super cool subways did not go down
because i like i said i have a gun or a
knife
i mean trapped underground somewhere
with [ __ ] no ninja turtle help no
spider-man help batman ain't coming
no
nobody's [ __ ] coming always coming
pigeon ladies not coming to help me
it's over
um
yeah so that was my experience in new
york oh so i went to the book of mormon
let me continue because we're an hour
and a half and we're trying to get out
of here because it's sunday night um i
went rosie goes hey was phantom of the
opera we had it we had it going
i can't believe people can sing like
that that's really cool you can remember
all that stuff the stage was the most
incredible things i've ever seen the
theatrics and the [ __ ] moving around
what a
boring ass show i fell asleep
not because i was doing this because i
went like this
and chose to go to sleep guys
i was so [ __ ] bored yeah that i was
like almost like
you make people sit this is the water
you give to your place that's how i feel
like this is what you make people sit
through [ __ ] you
it's been eight minutes this man singing
this [ __ ] please stop it are you just
ripping the pens is there oh i didn't
want to get kicked out oh that had been
amazing nah i didn't even remember
because uh
both times were on the edge
and those [ __ ] security people
are on your ass if you touch your phone
they're [ __ ] on your right you're
talking stop talking though they're on
it dude i wasn't
but every restaurant was smoking it up
nobody paid attention everybody has
opened doors and a ledge and a [ __ ]
plants on their the front so it's all
open airs i was ripping them just
waiting for waiters and then
letting it off and it was just taken
straight off out the door
i saw a couple people i saw look at me
but i mean it's not the people that work
there i don't give a [ __ ]
and uh it didn't smoke in their face so
[ __ ] you and um
family up oh my god that [ __ ] was so
whack
damn no wack in the terms of i'm bored
like
bored but wow
i didn't i don't know the story he's a
little [ __ ] okay if you [ __ ] follow
theater fan of the opera is the guy
for all the girls out there he's the guy
that's your friend
and he helps you out but you're dating
someone else like you didn't date me
and they won't stop dming you and
bugging you and doing all that weird
[ __ ] that's family opera he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what an [ __ ] you're scarred up so
you're like no you're gonna kill people
just wear the mask and just be a famous
opera singer
that's all i can think about any of this
[ __ ]
all i kept thinking at the end was
so you're just a little [ __ ] that's not
your girlfriend
bottom line sir uh he's [ __ ] forest
basically but he's just hey don't talk
forest wasn't complaining about it
though yes forrest gump wasn't
complaining he's the best man
he's amazing
god i love that movie so much
god it's so good
family opera if you'd like opera go
[ __ ] watch it but it's like me doing
this and just me doing this like yo
you're just talking
you're just talking
higher don't [ __ ] with me
don't do that make it me not to just
pass out on it's like it's dark
it's all that's another thing i was
exhausted bro yeah i was exhausted but
it's not even that i was just doing this
like
i am so [ __ ] bored
but they were like on a fake bow on
stage
blew my mind the [ __ ] that people can
really do
with like movement stage stages people
move ropes doing that blew my mind
anyway uh book of mormon [ __ ]
hysterical also i i my humor is a piece
of [ __ ]
fan of the opera if you like that stuff
go watch it watching it was incredi i
cannot believe that [ __ ] was
singing like that
it was shocking i don't know if you've
ever seen people do that i was
up this lady was singing [ __ ] up or
i'm like this is your voice [ __ ]
you're lucky you could do whatever you
want you could do whatever you want
just because you go like she could see
everybody saying opera yeah she's kind
of rude she's yeah she's mean but do you
ever hear her voice you can do whatever
you want you could be a piece of [ __ ]
like oh my god her voice was [ __ ]
insane but
man boring yeah that's what i'm saying
it's still a thing the fact that it's
still a thing that they're able to do
this every day day in and [ __ ] day
out everyone loved it though i thought
it was great
boring but oh my god everybody moving
around doing their thing this day just
like i said it was just incredible were
you the youngest people on there
or not so much no there was like 20 or
20 people over like 50. everyone else
that's the phantom of the opera yeah
everyone else is young everywhere
actually everything i went to
i noticed but real quick we went to a
place called dirt candy damn last night
this whole time change is really weird
to me last night went to a place called
dirt candy it's a vegan
fine dining place but when you look at
the man you go wait it's set course oh
that's what set courses like
hey here's the price and here's the
line of course i've never done that i
was like oh man i can't pick some [ __ ] i
want yeah [ __ ]
anyway they sat us right in front of
where they're making [ __ ]
and the dude that just moved there i
talked to him the whole time asking him
cause he's making sure i'm like yo this
is [ __ ] awesome he was cool he i know
he was high as hell but he was cool so i
mean he'd look like the type of dude
that would get high as hell i'm not
saying is high or was high but just in
case he gets in trouble or something but
he was mad cool
we ate like these little [ __ ] ass
dishes like i'm saying [ __ ] ass in
terms of size
whoa i might have been some of the best
food i read my life i'm sure wow
these [ __ ]
i always think like so what can i put on
this bread
a sauce
i'm a chef that's how i feel sometimes
like oh sauce on it
look at me but the [ __ ] they're doing it
was a tomato
every horse was a different vegetable
and the whole thing was made out of the
vegetable
whoa blew my [ __ ] mind there's a
carrot taco that i ate went this is one
of the best things i've ever made in my
life and i hate pickled [ __ ] yeah
i can't even explain the menu
shocking
whoa some of the coolest stuff i've ever
seen and it was all little dainty stuff
like stuff you see in magazines where
they're like putting it on
artisans yes
exactly and i'm looking around like
we stink like hash everyone here is like
wearing nice clothes and wearing glasses
i feel dumb
also i don't give a [ __ ] i just thought
of it like damn rosie
sometimes like sometimes i feel like you
know i should have gotten dressed
i should have dressed nicely
get your basketballs why does every
stink like hash
i was wearing i was wearing uh aaliyah
pants rosie bought me some
cargo shorts with pockets on the side i
felt like [ __ ]
aaliyah when i put them on like damn
[ __ ] i'ma stomp with my shoes and [ __ ]
leah's a singer yeah you know she wore
cool ass pants oh them tommy hilfiger i
don't know no no they're like the khaki
pants i wear oh he doesn't have a pocket
guys i don't really look like aaliyah
pants i'm just talking [ __ ] i thought
you meant like the aliyah [ __ ] dmx used
to wear where it had a leah on it
that'd be sick i'm just talking [ __ ]
yeah but i felt like a leah especially
being out there i felt i felt like a
shanty like damn
i got some sick ass pockets i didn't use
them but they looked cool i've worn
pockets on my pants on the outside since
like the fourth grade oh my god so it
was awesome
yeah yeah and i was wearing like [ __ ]
sneakers like yo what is this what new
york and then i started levitating you
got some tims and a scully on and yeah
and i called everybody kid everyone hey
kid
gore-tex and i started wearing all
gore-tex
that was it that's all that happened
and then i started i i asked for a
chopped cheese everywhere i heard that
so many times when i went to delis
yo there's six thousand dollars in new
york yeah there's
how do you pick one
it's just all got the same [ __ ] buy what
you live next to is that what it is i
guess so i missed even buffalo had we
had like sub shops like pizza shops we
had
there's a pizza there's 10 pizzas spots
on every corner
how did you stay in business
and then i sat there for five minutes
and watched them fill up an empty fill
up and
new york's so odd
it's a weird place it's it's cool it's
the most culturally diverse place i've
ever seen i've never heard that many
languages in my life
whoa yeah it's the only thing like it
that we got that's fine i'm going back
but i'm gonna smoke it out next time but
i loved it dude it was very cool super
cool uh the restaurants were
la we're [ __ ] lagging on the vegan
food bro
everything i ate there vegan besides
that pizza pizza was trash everything i
ate there vegan was better than i've had
here it's really surprising shocked the
[ __ ] out of me like we got farms out
here how come we're not crushing it like
that mm-hmm
and like a lot of vegans
there was so much vegan food man it was
kind of shocking like everywhere i
walked
oh [ __ ]
we had hello reservations at places we
looked at before that's why we didn't
really go to las platz but
yeah anyway we ate a bunch of [ __ ] uh i
feel a [ __ ] like a fat piece of [ __ ]
i feel like just games
all i did was walk around and eat
different people i'm sorry can we talk
about how [ __ ] high you were in that
3 000
challenge oh my god
it reminded me when you said that you're
like i feel like i'm folding over on
myself
[Music]
i felt in my body while i was editing
that [ __ ] video i could feel how high
you were my arms were feeling heavy and
slow
dude it was
is that the highest you've ever been no
you look so [ __ ] up
in those shots it was the shittiest
feeling off of high i've ever been
that's just felt like yeah that's what i
mean
i'm a [ __ ] confused like quicksand
that's how i felt like i'm like i'm good
i'm good
i'll show you a crash
i need water because like i said in the
video i almost threw up a few times and
i started filming at my house like i was
going what possessed you
like the fact that you woke up in the
middle of the night
and then recorded again
you woke up at 4 20 in the morning yeah
and then you woke back up again at like
seven in the morning it was the last yes
but i'm just saying because i wanted to
update i didn't want to go all right
guys i'm shit-faced you could've just
ended the [ __ ] video no i wanted
people to see like i want you to see me
five hours in and then like eight hours
and then i'll say bye because
you remember the day when you know they
came here oh i still feel [ __ ] up i
woke up four hours early just to like
try to shake up nah shake [ __ ] off
it doesn't work like that i don't give a
[ __ ] people talk [ __ ] about hhc you go
try to eat 3 000 of these things and see
how your night turns out
dude
it was way worse than the 5 000
milligram challenge
way worse the 5 000 i didn't feel like
that
i felt spinny
i just felt like
because the sugar on top of like
being so [ __ ] high and i was taking
mad dabs
dabs but that's just like
water like we're just dabbing like we're
just it's a function but like the
highness yeah the animals like you like
looked different you could tell in my
face yeah almost like a different color
yeah like i'm just like drained
like i'm gonna die i look [ __ ] gone i
look like somebody just got out of a
hangover like
give me water please that's how i felt
like please
yeah
yeah exactly i felt like literally i was
sitting there editing like [ __ ]
i could just feel it that's dedication
though to that [ __ ] video yeah go
check it out the dopagiola channel on
youtube i just dropped it two days ago
um
that three thousand milligram challenge
no
no it's intense uh-uh no thanks
i think i'm i'm getting to the point
where i'm like
what other challenges can i even
accomplish
just start doing the [ __ ] hanging upside
down or something humanly possible like
i think i don't see i don't see a lot of
people being able to smoke the 40 gram
joint without moving without getting up
without going to the bathroom just sit
there you got to do it on a tight rope
or some [ __ ] now you got to start you
see what i'm saying what else can i do i
take two gram dabs i'm not taking bigger
gram dabs let everybody else do that
i've seen 12 grand i've seen it
no thanks
what else could i do edible challenges
i've done
so
much that now i think about like
establish some new goals here yeah like
what
else can i do uh-huh
i don't know it'd be fun i'm not saying
like
i'm done i'm saying like yo
i'm what else done 100 gram joints they
don't get old either like uh just
because you did the 5000 challenge
before didn't lessen that 3 000 anymore
i get what you're saying you know but
you know me like when you're creating
videos like no i don't want to be
repetitive yeah yeah yeah i want to stay
and steer away but at the same time like
but it was [ __ ] awesome like
how many different ways can you like get
extremely [ __ ] up basically yeah
push yourself to the limit you got to
get like a goddamn iv next that's
it i'll figure it out though i can't
what you're saying we'll figure it out
um
[Music]
yeah that was a
that was not fun
go check it out adobe shop.com go check
it out it's
oh also
we talked about forbes in the last
episode or no oh yeah i think we did
yeah we've i think we had four oh well
now if you go to forbes just type in
on google type in dopaziola
forbes yeah
and it pops it takes a couple days to
index on google it's weird you know
what's even crazier do you see twitter
forbes tweeting us and [ __ ]
i did see that yeah
posted us on twitter bro let's go get
the [ __ ] out of here man so
thedobashop.com and the dope is yola
brain mind thing whatever you want to
call carrick i don't know what you call
it it's just me [ __ ] i don't
know um
we had an article in forbes all right we
got a [ __ ] article in forbes magazine
it says my name in it
it's long as [ __ ] it's like five pages
it's as long as [ __ ] the title is
this is parentheses probably the most
popular cannabis
content creator
in the world and it says meet dopaziola
it still blows my [ __ ] mind every
time i see that blows my mind
but check that out it's live now since
the last time it just went live it's
live now it's it's
unreal can't believe this [ __ ]
super cool one other thing i have to
talk about before we get out of here um
you we talked about aircon season one
nfts i don't know what that is
we've talked about it multiple times
we've talked about it more and i've told
you more like oh i get it now i now get
it but i'm not going to spend all my
money on nft it's not going to happen i
see my homies spending houses
do your thing not for me
but you know dopey shops do with nfts
because people ask this and i've had so
many peop
if there's a hundred people
40 of them like you're a dick you're
doing ft's you're a sellout [ __ ] you i'm
not watching you can pretend that i
didn't do it and the content didn't even
change i don't understand why people
wouldn't like nft because there's so
many scams there's like a say say a
rapper doesn't nft he's like yo
oh you get my nft automatically get this
uh free link to my new album week early
and they never do it oh they just cashed
out and then the nft drops because
nobody really wants man this is a scam
so everybody that paid the money went
so my shit's worth nothing
oh
[ __ ] all right
but for the people saying that about me
obviously you don't watch a lot
yeah i'm not a scammer [ __ ] you it's
like a membership club surrounded
centered around cool
exactly so on twitter dopest nft just go
follow it all the information's there i
have to talk about this because it's
getting close it's getting close
and i'm going to talk and i know a lot
of people in the chat like bro don't
you're on the doc so many people oh they
got him too
[ __ ] you
nft you know what it could be a blank
file who cares it's not about the art
the art's great it's [ __ ] cool
it's about what it is
it's a membership pass i'm gonna get
into it a little bit we can't talk about
it yet what we're gonna do but it's a
membership pass say you get the nft and
you on the dopeyshop.com you just type
in your portal
and you have a different
link you have a different
tab
on our shop that only you have and has
[ __ ] that only you're allowed to get on
earth nobody else we're not going to put
it out it's only for you and what's the
coolest part about it
you have the vote you get to pick what
you
your hands like yo
who do you guys want on the show all
right cool pick them all right you
picked them remember yo all you
[ __ ] you guys you're doing this
oh by the way you can all sit here like
it's more like inclusive like yo
the pen flavor you suggested is now in
your hand and you're the only one that
has it like it's and that's just that's
a one percent of what we're doing the
other [ __ ] is like right now on youtube
check us out the dopest shop on youtube
we give away ps5
uh halo xbox just gave away the
skateboard cust i want that [ __ ] i want
it so bad but we i have to ship it
we're [ __ ] not going to be cheap i
know but i was just like dude i wanted
it i want that i would pay for it it's
so cool we're giving away
just for people that
will follow us and
enter the give the sweepstakes the
sweepstakes is just
customer stuff we'll pick some a name or
we'll pick somebody that's subscribed
we're just yo thank you for supporting
us that's what we're doing so this nft
that's what we're doing without the nft
all right so with the nft you're gonna
look at that's what we're doing for
people it's not even exclusive what are
we gonna do with the exclusive [ __ ] i
can't talk about everything yet but
we can just say las vegas all right
we're announcing very soon i'll tell you
about it after we're announcing it very
soon
i i can't hint about it too crazy you
know what by the time this comes out
maybe
it's coming out tomorrow yeah hopefully
vegas
how cool would it be if like
oh we had like a party
that only you were allowed to come to
i don't know that'd be cool
that'd be sick oh you mean like a legal
smoke out yeah but yeah but not like an
event just nft holders like what do you
mean like only the [ __ ] with
the membership pass can come that's the
whole point right that's the point vegas
new york florida we're gonna travel so
people have to travel so far that's the
point we want to like
we're not going to like yo pocket the
nft money no no here's the percentage
that we're putting straight back yeah
because we're going to actually do it
merch that only you're allowed to have
i mean dude and plus the per partner
with illa i didn't tell you about who
we're partnered with doing the nfts illa
all right
12-time
grammy
producer did i even tell you about who
we're working with he does all eminem
[ __ ] um
i'll show you him after shout out to
ella he's very heavy in the nft world
though but he's a big time producer but
he does
him and hash house are crazy on the nfts
anyway we have him helping us with all
this so he's like no no i've seen too
many artists just scam out the back door
and then he we introduced him to us he's
like wait you have a
fan base like this
can we what do you think about i have
tease like nah that was eight months ago
he took so long for me to convince me i
know i'm good i i'm nfts and then he
explained it what about like a
membership it's just just think of it as
a [ __ ] costco card right
now tell me more like that's that's
[ __ ] awesome it seems like an obvious
thing
if it wasn't called it just seems like
it wasn't called nft if it was called
the dopaziola membership pass nobody
would talk [ __ ] to me and it just
happens to be an nft
like that's his pass nobody would be
talking [ __ ] what if i made it a
baseball card and sent it to you are you
gonna start talking keep talking [ __ ]
with a qr code yeah with a qr code
if if enemity's bugging you
don't think of it that way this anyway
this is just one thing we're doing and
there's just things we've already done
it's not like we're saying we're gonna
we've already given away thousands of
dollars worth of things just just to say
thank you that's how you keep it going
what else can we do what a smart
business does yeah we have the wheel you
guys already know
we're just trying to find out which car
we're gonna give away we already got it
all ready to go
motherfucker's gonna drive home in a
prize just for [ __ ]
a youtuber they followed that one time
they
one of sweepstakes and like yeah i'm
driving it
i'm driving my prize
come on man we're like gas card
i mean what about insurance right they
gotta get insurance we'll pay the first
month we're thinking about all of this
as a real thing like who they can just
drive away
but if they drop they live in indiana
yeah like no we'll fly them out
drive home
or buy it in their city we'll fly out
film it drive home buy home
we're trying to do really fun stuff
we're trying to like be a real place
this is
anyway thedopashop.com the dopest nft on
twitter the dopest shop on youtube just
check us out man
um we're trying all right we're trying
it's [ __ ] awesome we can't say what
it's going to be yet
we do have a certain collab coming out
and yes it's going to go all 50 states
it's going to blow your mind
i don't think i even told you
what the [ __ ] i guarantee you we're
gonna be the world's first pers for
company to do this
all right a lot of world's first coming
recently all right there you go guys
we're supposed to keep this at an hour
it's an hour 49 let's get the [ __ ] out
of here
[ __ ] i'm sorry
red city
it's okay we've been here for a minute
i know that could be a big week sir
beer's warm yup
i know how we've been here for a minute
that's a little bit warm at the bottom
all right um
you got anything else you want to add on
this i don't think so i think we hit
everything i'm just i feel really great
it's an amazing little
chapter we're in right now yeah the
heading into the end of season two early
season three
yeah yeah yeah exactly
so you know i just i feel great i'm just
i'm just feeling like you know
not scared or nothing i'm just
feeling just like myself for the first
time really
house is good things are situated we got
this deal going i'm just ready for this
this next chapter just trying to keep
the [ __ ] going
perfect
perfect
it's the first time you get to chill and
you're
you're just a rapper this week
i'm thinking about it like a podcast so
i'm saying you don't have to you don't
have
to take anybody to school oh yeah no god
i know it's it's a cool little week when
this happens
waiting on 12 comedians to go hey marty
i need this today right now i don't care
what time it is
this is the first time and you're not
rapping because i need a deal
you're right because
i'm i make music mm-hmm it's because i
want it it's different yeah it's
different it's definitely sure yeah no
man and i'll always have respect for the
like i have so much respect for people
in that position that i
i was in of like
just wanting
and just like hoping and just like
having that belief in them i've i mean
i've had good friends of mine in my in
the music business that like
i've linked them up with like a young
up-and-coming artist and they kind of
played around with it
danced around with their
with their feelings and i get real
[ __ ] pissed i've
ruined at least
one really good relationship over that
um just because like i don't know i just
want to be an example for people that
cause [ __ ]
10 12 15 20 years who knows how long
it's going to take but that's what you
sign up for with this [ __ ]
you know and so it's just i want to
highlight the success because i spent a
lot of time highlighting the struggle
and [ __ ] also
you
pronounce your words so crisp
oh that thought is never crossed my eyes
not ruined like this [ __ ] i say
elementary
elementary documentary documentary
marty i think people make fun of how i
say it but you speak proper when you say
[ __ ] go damn
rude
but you said her and i was like
like that was like not ruined
gotcha i don't know i just thought of it
like
i mumbled my words a lot and then i
noticed also
if i had an accent you would think i'm
from the east coast on the words i use
all the [ __ ] people were saying i'm like
yo i hear that [ __ ] match that's just
mad crazy what's going on hey this
[ __ ] wildest [ __ ] out here wait
i like you guys you see all the same
words i do and i don't know where they
just accumulated in my vocabulary
so yeah i talk
i jumble my words and i talk like i'm
selling dubs uh-huh and you talk about
practice i don't know i'm a low-talking
mumbling [ __ ] myself so i don't
hear no mumbles coming around
so marty just sounds like future i don't
know
[ __ ] mumble had this album
rap going yeah get my scissors going yo
have you ever spleen no oh okay no not
everyone this is slipped manatee back in
the day is that
no
no i don't i wouldn't i wouldn't that's
something like that crosses in the area
of [ __ ] i wouldn't do i just wish it
wasn't bad for you because i would just
be drinking it right now
like liquid heroin i wouldn't do regular
heroin no hell no but i would love to go
like yo thomas what are you doing you
know what i was
sick
because you know what i do i drink and
go to sleep wake up
not tired anymore but i you know [ __ ]
don't work like that i can't do drugs
um
yeah so sorry last question
will you will there ever be the dopest
lien what yeah you haven't heard a
million people asking for that comments
syrup yeah okay
okay what's the difference
you're talking about like like syrup
like
lyra syrup okay when you say lean you go
it makes me think drugs sorry
a hundred percent we have uh a couple
drink ideas coming up nice it just takes
a while because our packaging
it's a real company so it takes a minute
it's not trap [ __ ] so we can't just like
slap it sell it can't do it yeah once
you decide on a new sku there's a
[ __ ] whole price it takes this
[ __ ] month yeah and then if we get it
and go i don't like it two weeks later
[ __ ] i gotta wait two more weeks [ __ ]
send me five next time please i'll just
number em and that's what we do now
that's how you should do the next
challenge you got no more eating gummies
oh we have something going on soon all
right
yeah yeah
we may have like
something super awesome coming out soon
that you're gonna go go great idea
i know
i even i went oh my god that's such a
good [ __ ] great idea yes
so there's only a few times where i go
i love my brain
and when i do that i know it's gonna be
great it's a good one yeah yeah um
all right so we talked about a bunch of
[ __ ] today uh new york i just got back
today i actually have new york pizza in
my stomach from last night
if you want to say that i brought some
east coast crosstalk right out here
um
yeah i did
i still didn't get no bagel and it
bumped me out but i'm going back soon
i'm going back soon because it was
[ __ ] cool and i do
do want to go back when there's a little
bit of snow out there that would be cool
did the central park ride that was
pretty awesome first thing you pointed
out that's the pigeon lady that's where
she was in homeland oh i love this place
already uh it's the first thing he says
well that's plaza hotel or kevin
mcallister conned yeah i know what
you're talking about man like as soon as
he says
i was all hyped up man um yeah so i just
like movies um marty's about to make
some make some music
we're chilling we're hanging out we've
got a lot of videos coming out if you
haven't watched the dopey's yellow
channel go watch it because a lot of
videos been coming out and [ __ ] pace
yes and tomorrow adventures this today
tomorrow comes out monday so tomorrow uh
adventures of viola story time we did a
story it's like 40 minutes long so i'm
gonna drop that tomorrow
from this video so thank you guys so
much for watching and if you haven't
watched it don't watch the rock and
kevin hart one go watch the robin
williams jumanji today please all right
just go watch it's just such a fun movie
if you have kids
watch their faces
when they go wow because that's was
that's what i was doing the plane today
whoa i forgot
i forgot about the mosquito that's crazy
anyway go watch the jumanji go watch
happy gilmore go watch everything that's
fun thank you guys so much for being
here um this has just been one catch-up
episode because i have been gone all
week
sleep deprived
and i'm tired so we just keep going we
didn't talk about any of this i know i
haven't talked to marty at all since
i've been gone about what's been going
on because i wanted to save it for the
episode
and yeah that was it i walked around i
gained weight i think
but we're going to be okay
thank you so much for being here a bunch
of new stuff coming out go uh check out
the dope as usual or dope as usual
podcast on instagram dope as usual
podcast twitter go check out
dobasuspodcast.com
uh for all push trees gear pushtrees.com
thedopistshop.com as you guys have heard
us talk about that all 50 [ __ ]
states hopefully that's not what's
getting us age restricted
we'll see thank you guys for being here
appreciate you marty anything else thank
you guys
appreciate you let's keep this
[ __ ] pushing
all right guys from marty and i thank
you so much for being here this is the
dopes usual podcast and today we have
talked about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between and some new york stuff all
right so shout out to everybody from new
york shout out to everybody i met out
there have a dope ass day
good outro yeah that was
good come on kid
i didn't meet necro
i didn't run into 50 cent
i didn't meet jason alexander
damn
because i'm from new york
what
champagne bottles where's cameron
[Music]